Let us continue this exercise a little bit further.
Imagine that the teacher gives this as a third example to the AI program.
This time again you have three bricks, but the two vertical bricks
are touching each other. So here is a representation of this input example.
Three bricks, the two vertical bricks are supporting this brick at the top,
however, the two bricks are touching each other. Recall, this is the current
concept definition that the AI program has. It mus support links here.
And here is the representation of the new example. And the AI program knows that
this is a negative example. How might the AI program refine or
specialize this particular current definition, so that this negative example is
excluded? Well, AI program may say that the current definition can be devised in
such a way that for these two bricks, where one is left of the other one,
these two bricks cannot touch each other. This particular symbol means not.
So it is saying that this brick does not touch that one. And
we have bi-datashield links. Because this one cannot touch the other one, and
that one cannot touch this one. This is called a forbid-link heuristic. So,
here some particular link, in this particular case touches, is being forbidden.